good evening and welcome to fox news
primetime i'm brian kilmeade and tonight
we'll examine joe biden's crisis
on our border we're going to talk to
laura trump and former ice director tom
holman
but we're going to circle back to them
in just a moment but first it's all
about the children
don't take my word for it just ask
speaker nancy pelosi
learn three most important issues facing
the congress from a whole time in
congress have always said the same thing
our children our children our children
their health
their education the economic security of
their families
a healthy safe environment which they
can thrive
world at peace in which they can reach
their fulfillment it's always for me
about the children
that was nancy pelosi back in january
but her talking point is evergreen
anytime democrats want to pass
legislation whether it's education
immigration or gun control they always
talk about children kids
if you weren't paying attention you
would think that the democrats are for
the party
of children they are four kids but one
close look would show you they're
anything
but that they say that for the children
when they're cracking down on legal gun
ownership
background checks assault weapons ban
but when you bring up the soaring
violence in democratic cities like
chicago new york
los angeles they are not interested but
they should you got 159 kids
who have died killed since 2016 due to
gun violence our biggest inner cities
uh number since 2016 but radio silence
from nancy pelosi
from democrats all democrats about their
children what about school shutdowns got
to keep the kids safe right
well democrats are scared silent by the
teachers union who continues to push
hard to keep kids
out of the classroom for almost a year
they say they're doing it for the
children
but we knew better we knew the stats
schools were safe for kids
of the more than one million coveted
cases nationally only two percent
resulted in hospitalizations
and less than one tenth of one percent
lead to deaths but the democrats and
unions forced students like
third grader leah to stay home and
struggle to learn
when the teacher is like in the
classroom she looks more at the people
in the classroom than in remote
sometimes
it's like sad because you don't have any
like friends close to you
or you can't go outside sad right
meanwhile teen suicide attempts
overdoses skyrocketed under the
crippling weight
of coveted lockdowns and school closures
are the democrats for
those children now is the crisis along
our border spirals out of control
the democrats continue to claim that
they're the party for the children
first they deny that we have a crisis
then they say they
have compassion for the thousands of
migrant children arriving on our border
every month every day
that was what jen saki said today
children presenting at our border
who are fleeing violence who are fleeing
prosecution
who are fleeing terrible situations is
not a crisis
our alternative is to send children back
on this treacherous journey
that is not in our view the right choice
to make we are taking steps to ensure
that when
kids come to the border we look and see
if they have a phone number in their
pocket so we can call the family member
and get them to those
family members as quickly as possible so
comments like that
sound like they're compassionate but
they're not they're the ghost sign for
migrants desperate to pursue their
american dream not the legal way the
biden way time and time again
the biden administration's comments have
inspired people to make a treacherous
journey to our southern border sometimes
they
bring their children with them sometimes
they send their children alone
and put them in the care of coyotes
human traffickers is that humane is that
compassionate
some of those children will be sexually
assaulted lonely they'll take that
lonely journey some will not survive it
and those who do make it across the
board are often held in cramped cages
because
there's nowhere else to keep them look
at these kids think about what the white
house is saying to convince them
to come here and ask yourself this
question are the democrats
for these children do they matter